what if he accidents take your birth
control pills
if I
you chose this is the next thing I never
open you up on I'm not so no birth
control pills he is using protection
I'm yes so there's no like not taking
blood control pills to try to get
pregnant Jesus Christ this is worse than
I thought
so he played me when he told me
basically that
if you get pregnant you're welcome the
child and he's using mere contraception
yeah man who does not want to have a
child at all costs
wow unbelievable
she needs to stand up for herself
he caught me stringing her along
I believe in Bilal love shot as much as
he tells her he will move up the
timeline and recognize that this is
important for her but I'm glad I've
opened up her eyes to see it's a
possibility that
he might not do that
I felt like there's no more holding back
so I gave him an ultimate term for the
first time oh that is good I said to him
if he does not give me an answer after
nine months
there could be no no more Bell alanchai
he needs to see that you can survive
without him and you're not just a
handbag or a trophy to be walked around
to be part of something peaceful but
listening to you now
you've grown the balls that I think you
need
so I want you to tell me
if you had to choose between your
marriage and having a baby
which one with each other
like right now how I feel
Alex was having a baby
I'm glad she stuck up for herself but
she needs to toughen up and don't waver
in her opinion because basically that is
whole
he's going to basically get his way with
her so if she's not pregnant in nine
months
she just needs to go leave him
stick to the nine months
observe him
and look at if he's still using male
contraception yeah
but remember do not under any
circumstances
allow nine months to pass and you don't
make drastic changes
[Music]